remercie encore en football maintenant
le rêve est fini pour les amateurs de
quevilly
mais ils n'ont pas à rougir ils ont bien
résisté hier face au psg ils se sont
inclinés 1 à 0
l'entraîneur a tout de même féliciter
ses joueurs dont il est fier
même sentiment chez les supporters aaron
transit michael cariou la belle aventure
du petit poucet s'achève dans les larmes
quevilly n'ira pas au stade de france la
fin d'un rêve pour ces footballeurs
amateurs battu d'un tout petit but par
les professionnels du paris saint
germain qui pourtant est de ceux-là fois
content du parcours
mais déçu ça réfléchit pas du stade de
france même si on a tout donné comme se
sentent autant dans gm dans un musée
répond fait vivre un moment comme par
les fantastiques attend ils sont vingt
mille à soutenir les jaune et noir face
à des parisiens fébrile maladroit erding
multiplient les occasions gâchées
0 0 à la mi temps dans l'intimité du
vestiaire normand l'entraîneur de
quevilly motive ses troupes
ça va jouer sur un truc et ça sent
mauvais ça sent bon temps a dû
s'accrocher c'est eux qui sont alger la
mise à la 51e minute le psg va trouver
de quoi se rassurer
erding de la tête trouve enfin le chemin
des filets 1-0 et pourtant dans les bars
de la petite ville de la banlieue
rouennaise
pas question de se décourager
on y croit encore on désespère pas
arrêts de jeu coup franc de la dernière
chance et c'est le poteau qui sauve
paris 1-0 on en restera là
le 1er mai en finale face à monaco dans
un match sous haute surveillance
policière
le fait j'essaie supporters tenteront de
décrocher une huitième coupe de france
quant aux amateurs de quevilly après
avoir éliminé deux clubs de ligue 1 ils
quittent la compétition la tête haute
les normands sont passés tout près d'un
formidable exploit